Jesse AKA MTV Jesse AKA Bloody Sunday
Jesse Sunday
Etc on and on and on you looking like uh
like you lost like a whole one of
yourselves with this weight loss and
this transformation you look good man
thanks man what how cuz obviously couple
years ago you had kind of like dived in
on like just like redirecting your life
and in terms of like getting clean off
of alcohol cuz you were you know you had
a you recognize you had some sort of
problem with alcohol however severe not
severe it might have been yeah it feels
like you've dived all the way in on like
kind of a lifestyle change in terms of
fitness and I always see you sparring
and you're just always sweating and uh
you know shirtless sweating and
shirtless but but what well first of all
obviously what sparked that and how long
has The Journey been for you where you
really like are very consistent cuz it's
you could start
most people start and stop start and
stop start and stop the consistency is
important that I think that was the big
change is cuz I was that guy I mean I've
lost 30 to 50 pounds like 10 times in my
life and I [__] got sick and tired of
being that guy like yeah you know what I
mean and it's [__] annoying I mean
even just this last week that went by I
like I went on the scale after like my
dad was down and like whatever and I'm
like 7 pounds heavier and I just F cold
stop I was like yo you're not that guy
like you're not bouncing back to being
like [__] you can slip into it dude
so quick Y and uh and I think it's when
uh you stop say like for me I I weigh
myself every Monday and I'm like it's
the second you're like no I know I'm
heavier this week so I'm going to weigh
myself next Monday I think that's D hold
yourself account go weigh yourself look
at it write it down and then be like get
back like and also weigh yourself at
night cuz if you weigh yourself in the
morning that I can't do I do I'm naked
you're naked I take as as soon as you
wake up and you're naked you're like I
don't know why it is if you weigh
yourself like right when you wake up you
weigh way less oh yeah crazy you look
even better you do I know you'll be like
damn like my food processed I'm not
don't have a I'm not I don't have a food
baby right now I even make sure after my
shower I'm like fully dry I can't have
wet hair yeah because it's a little
extra weight yeah damn I shave my pubes
I [__] just listen it all counts he
said my pubes are going down the do you
shave your pubes over the toilet or in a
trash bag let me think it's been a
minute actually cuz that was a joke let
me think oh I mean I got to ask I think
over a toilet you got to do over the
toilet yeah you don't want to be the guy
shaving your pubes over the trash and
then like yeah wait wa I have a wife
over the toilet someone does it over the
trash I don't think I've ever done that
I think I think some people have done
that
actually it my uh co-host little brother
did that they they share a place on my
radio show and he talked about how his
uh little brother shaved his pubes and
it was all over the side of the trash
Cannon and uh you got to clean up after
too cuz it's always around the toilet se
you got to do the little you got do
paper towel yep you got to get the it's
almost like a paper towel is more
stickier than you imagine when you're
cleaning pubes off of a toilet yeah it
grabs them it grabs them man it does n
it's it's dope to see everything going
on with you man obviously the last time
you were on the show was like not too
far after we launched the show I mean it
was maybe like four or five months after
we launched the podcast yeah um it's
been a minute man it's been a minute
that was like kind of right after you
had um not right after you had left nek
but I guess you had kind of broke in
your silence it was right after you
dropped the first YouTube video kind of
talking about of the new like direction
of content that you were doing yeah um
and I don't think I've I sold the
company at that point though no you did
not I was like that is correct because
shortly after that we had me and you had
started collabing on some pranks um we
had I some of the best dude of best
episodes we ever did was I get stopped
all the time really and they're always
like dude the prank with the guy guy who
who wrapped like a bear and and and and
a koi fish and and Simba my boy you know
Simba who's huge you know at the time he
was on the come up he still is on the
come up but he's a lot bigger than he
was then he even brings that [__] up to
me he'll be like dude that [__] was
crazy like people still ask me about
like about that whole situation really
there was a Snow the Product one we did
that for whatever reason that was with
Steve right it was with Steve and for
whatever reason the like real version of
that prank did not
drop I think I don't know was it cuz it
was I think it was like we shot it as a
nek video well that's what I was going
to say I know I think you guys had shot
something and I think at that at that
time that was like a situation where
Steve was in it and I think they they
the real footage of that was supposed to
possibly come out on nek yeah but we had
like a kind of a diet version oh I think
I know what happened that was around um
cuz like me and Kyle were kind of
shooting our own things anyways it
wasn't very public but like yeah so the
idea was towing cars as a prank yeah and
so I went to you and we shot that we
brought Steve and we had a segment we
were going to do for the video but then
I think they got sued or someone got I
think like the team got arrested for
that prank I think that and then that's
they couldn't upload the footage or or
they couldn't finish the so there's like
really dope footage of this sow the
product prank that we'll never see the
light of day yeah but it was really good
I got it on some drives probably she had
like her Jeep was hooked onto a tow
truck and she was trying to back out and
the wheels were spinning and she's like
freaking out she has her girlfriend in
the car and uh I think Steve was just
saying the most disrespectful sexist
[__] to this it was hilarious it was so
funny he was like talking about like
well yeah I know girls can't drive I
mean you're a woman oh that's what it
was yeah yeah it was it was Peak Peak
Steve will do we can't let you drive
because you're a woman 100% it was it
was good man um it that that's what I
was going to say man recently obviously
uh it was so awesome to
see uh obviously the long way everybody
ever since the full send podcast launch
was waiting on you to go on there so it
was dope to see you guys chat and kind
of talk about um the good old days and
some of the early pranks that you guys
had and then they kind of you gave it a
listen yeah I watched the whole thing
yeah I think the day dropped uh and then
I watched the uh the New York one where
you guys were security guards oh yeah
yeah very it just was like
nostalgic I get a lot of people have hit
me up since that video and been like
yeah it was like the perfect nostalgic
thing to do together that like brought
back like CU a lot of people I think
they they got brought into NK because of
that Coachella video we did so it was
like their like first [__] thing they
seen so they were just stoked to see
that yeah I just like I think that
that's what I miss you guys I just miss
that kind of content cuz it doesn't
really exist anymore and I don't think
Kyle's focused on making that kind of
[__] anymore and so it was just dope to
see you know what I mean feeding off
each other kind of yeah and just you
know like I I I just think some of you
guys' pranks were just some of the best
[__] like you guys would really like you
know whether it's you and and uh Steve
obviously Steve's face I don't even
think it'd be shown anywhere on YouTube
from what I've heard right not even his
hand man it's [__] sad not even his
hand apparently I heard that yeah was
talk about doing a podcast with him or
something he be off camera and like or
that's what it was I think he did the
Donald Trump one or something happened
and his was in it and they were like
flagging it and it was like what it's
[__] Bonkers dude that poor guy man I
really feel bad for him because like he
seem such a sweet dude and he was doing
so much like look he was doing some like
pushing the limit type [__] but he also
was giving away so much money to like
random families like I remember he had
that random lady he was taken on the
road with him everywhere the black chick
like I always thought I mean I I I miss
him on YouTube I haven't checked him out
on Rumble to see if the pranks are the
videos are still of of uh the quality
that they were but yeah when you're
deplatformed it's hard to I don't know
like yeah they
recogniz I think it was cuz it was his
like audio but then they were like oh he
not in it and then they said no like I
think they used like his hand I could be
[__] wrong but I remember hearing
that somewhere but